hey one of the things you and I need as
entrepreneurs is freed up energy okay
and freed up stress in our minds to be
able to use our creativity to make our
business work but sometimes we can't do
that why let me explain it to you back
in 2003 hours in that forty nine
thousand dollars and I had all these
other credit cards and I fit with this
one guy said I am so sick and tired of
all these calls and all these things I
want to pay off my debt how do I start
he said the first thing you got to do is
you got to make a list of all your
credit card debt that you have and don't
pay off the one that's the biggest
amount of debt pay the one that's
consuming the most interest so 35% pay
that off first then go to 22 percent 19%
16 percent
I said that's brilliant I did that and I
paid off my debt what does this have to
do what I'm telling you what energy and
having enough time and your brain to
think about it our brain your brain my
brain thinks about certain things
throughout the day okay some of us spend
most of our time thinking about one
topic let me explain you may be thinking
about money every day family health
business school party in politics sports
friends it doesn't matter but there's
always one that sucks up the most energy
out of your brain and if you're going to
use this anyways what if we could put it
in something like our business that
helps it grow let me explain it to you
so imagine for imagine if you from
morning till night all you think about
is I have twenty two thousand dollars a
dead I'm late on my car payment I'm late
on this it's as if you're underwater and
you're trying to figure out which way to
swim that's the land but you don't even
know all you're trying to do is breathe
so your brain doesn't have the energy to
think about how to grow the business
step number one go pay off that debt
it's taking 41 percent of your brain
some of you may be watching is you
saying I'm so sick and tired of fact
that I'm out of shape summer is here
everyone wants me to go to the beach
your swimming pool I say no because I
don't want to take off my shirt I have a
belly now I don't feel good about myself
well why don't you go lose that thirty
pounds so it doesn't consume 20 percent
of your brain or you have a friend that
completely messes with you they're
absolutely negative they were knowing
they're they're constantly taking shots
at you will it get rid of that friend
maybe you have a girlfriend or boyfriend
you're dating right now that's wasting
your time you know for a fact you're not
going to end up with him we're not going
to end up with her breakup already
dumped on
move on because it's consuming your
creative creativity in your mind and the
energy once you do that you know what
happens with this this box freed up time
can go into business this box that's
thinking about health it's no longer
thinking about health it's going
straight to business now you can grow
your business now you can scale your
business now you can actually start
thinking about by dreams what I want to
live what do I want to do who do I want
to marry what places do I want to go see
how do I want to conclude to society
what do I want to do for my mom my dad
my kids man I'm excited about life
because I have more time to focus on
fewer things that gives me the highest
rate of return so I have a better chance
of winning in life so this week make the
list eliminate put a formula and take
that bigger percentage into the one
thing such as business and go succeed in
a big way